don't really know what you just said and
I want to I want to hear you you just
you just finished writing your book or
no or it's now released yeah so that it
comes out I don't know when we're
releasing this but made tighter net
lemons come out on one relation and
either well hopefully it's already out
and then comes out yeah it just came out
then on Amazon Kindle audio anywhere you
get a book what is the name of the book
it's called free roll and give us a
little description for people that don't
know your your background in your story
so the shortest version is a kid that
grew up in a small town in Wyoming yeah
when I was five my dad went away to
prison yeah and then I'd see him once in
a while my mom told me he was at college
so they would say he got out every
couple years on spring break and he
would come visit us and then he
disappeared from the age like 12 to 20
and then I was going to college in
Phoenix I got a letter from him one day
I'm just saying that he he would be at
the airport in like three days anyone to
see me so I went to see him without
weird because this was before 9/11 so
you could go gate to gate yeah and I had
no idea what my own dad looked like [ __ ]
so I was just wandering around and then
I saw of course I like a guy in a wife
beater and ponytail brown pants like it
there's my deadbeat father look like
yeah so then I uh you know ran over gave
him a hug and then he said you know he
was moving to Vegas
he had a cocktail waitress girlfriend
that I don't know how he got to
mountains in in college and he so he's
moved to Vegas so then he invited me he
said I was invited anytime so then I
ended up dropping out of college and I
moved to Vegas to try to be a pirate at
the Treasure Island I trust my genius
idea that would be the dream job yeah
and then I I actually got the dream job
I was a runner yeah for a bunch of
professional gamblers yes so I would
just run up and down the strip carry
hundreds of thousand dollars of cash
what does a runner mean so I thought
just that I liked so I worked for these
guys and they were like older guys that
bet out of the office so then I had to
run up and down the strip and bet sports
games where they told me to go and I had
to beat the other runners so back then
it was more before like Twitter and the
Internet
so big right we would get information
before you know we'd get information
maybe five ten minutes before the
casinos and you would then want to place
the bet before other runners placed a
bet because that would affect the line
because in the line would move so you're
placing large sums of money yeah as much
as they would take so what what does
that mean like my boss would always say
people always like what's your limit
he's like just go outside and look up
that's my limit so you know we'd work
with the casinos because they would only
so I could bet like twenty twenty-five
thousand yeah because they don't want to
take a three million dollar bet on yeah
and it wasn't always
I mean let's say you know the Lions are
playing in a quarterback who's a
quarterback Matt staffs avid effort so
Stafford's out we'd maybe know that so
then I would run in there and they'd say
my limit was twenty five thousand so I'd
say let me bet against the Lions for
twenty five thousand yeah and then once
I got the bet then I pulled a sports
book directors aside and I'd say hey you
want you might want to look at that game
and then then I take it off the board
and that would that would stop me from
like sending in a drunk guy in a suit
right that in two hundred fifty thousand
they think they got a sucker so we kind
of worked it we all you know then would
still honor your bed yeah but you would
just kind of help them and then
hopefully they would that's yeah so back
then the I didn't know we would get
information who that yeah well you know
just protected them from and we weren't
always right and sometimes if they were
heavy on a game it would pull me aside
and go hey were we need like forty on
this game can you guys do anything and
then I would call my boss and go hey
there they're heavy on that yeah on the
Tigers can we bet we didn't bet baseball
we couldn't be baseball but Pistons or
something yeah and then we would so we
would give them some you know we'd help
each other they would they would they
would adjust a spread for you or
something well anytime I bet the line
would move they'd take it down why was
that [ __ ] big that did max and they
knew if I bet something so this and this
is what the book is about yeah well and
it books more of a relationship of
trying to have a relationship with my
dad then my dad stole eighty thousand
for me and then I try to kill my dad and
then okay a lot of stuff like that
happened so I'm not laughing at you no
no I think I don't know if anyone has
ever sat in that chair and said I tried
to kill my dad yeah and I believed them
so the book is now out and you were
recording the voices for audible
were you invited we'll just seeing this
microphone so I did the audible uh last
week and I had to do like nine-hour days
but then my buddy's like this was for
the audiobook for the audio yeah so he
was like I got my room you know he had
some rapper buddies I had a studio and
they were going to give me like a
discounted rate and then I was like you
know cuz you know just a broke comedian
I was like yeah save I can say 500 bucks
and you were gonna have them do what
like read it no so then I have to write
had to read it and then they had to
produce it so that was like the hardest
[ __ ] I've ever done so I really took me
because you you know you'd think it
would be easy I was talking trash was
like I got this one take like jay-z and
then I get in the studio and I would
just mess up my own sentences and then I
wrote these words yeah half the time i
co-wrote this [ __ ] but actually reading
it and going through was hard and then
so lucky i went with my friend who's
like a radio producer and I did it but I
didn't realize how emotional the book
would make me at time right because my
there's bad parts in the beginning about
my dad just beat up my mom and all this
bad stuff right okay so I'd start crying
and then I was like god I'm glad I
wasn't with a studio full of rats and
every card white ass cracker over here
came yeah I think they had have been
crying too they'd have been mad that I
put him in that situation was it
therapeutic to put these stories down
yeah you know a lot of it I didn't
people always like worried about my life
about it like I didn't remember a lot of
the bad stuff to do that before I was
like 5 so when I interviewed my mom you
know about about the book that was the
hardest part is watching my mom have to
go through it again and yeah tell me
what she you know we just tell me what
she went through so I didn't I didn't my
mom did a good job of protecting us from
what was really going on so so I kind of
learned a lot from the situation I hated
my dad anyway but and to know that it
was like mom I'm glad we'd try to get
him i I think I interviewed my parents
for a CD I did a while ago and it wasn't
anything as emotional more just about
their lives and I'm so glad I did that
oh yeah it's there's so much that they
don't tell us yeah yeah to protect us
yeah or just because they're busy
raising you yeah yeah yeah I'd enjoyed
the whole process of interviewing you
know I interviewed a lot of people from
my past
and just learned a lot about my life I
didn't know so that part was cool Wow
for sure so if there's a cool it's the
hardest thing I've ever done I never
imagined how I mean it took me two and a
half years and it's just how did you
type it like I'm senator Mac on a
computer I'm suckin on Microsoft Word
yeah I was yeah it was on Microsoft Word
and then I would uh you know I try to
get a thousand words a day yeah for a
while and then the editing process is
just so extensive and just being broke
comedian I hadn't reached out to friend
so you know had a lot of friends are
like I'm a great editor and they gave me
their edits and then I gave to someone
else and like has anyone looked at this
and then they took all fix it I mean I
probably went through eighteen nineteen
people at the end of the edit yeah and
what a day it is editing more cutting no
more just dumb [ __ ] by me just grammar
and yes I mean bad see Michael I don't
know anything I mean oh yeah I mean I
don't think anybody knows that yeah so
I'm gonna dropped out of junior college
through time yeah I'm not I'm not a real
scholar so I think that's the funny part
when I tell people I wrote a book they
look at me like yeah really really don't
like that I can write a book if you yeah
um what did your dad when you said your
dad was in prison what did he go for I
just drugs his big drug dealer a big
drug deal yeah so he I mean he got in
trouble for I think it just built up but
when he gotten the biggest stuff was
just uh
cross state line drugs yeah yeah we were
talking on your podcast about how I
think I think I was telling the story
about how when I moved from LA to New
York I found in my moving van I found
like a lot of weed yeah that was mine
but I forgot that I had stored it there
and then we and you started chatting on
your pockets a really funny conversation
because we were like how easy would it
be to just ship drugs three moving
companies yeah I think we even did a
little business plan on your budget but
it that's pretty funny now to hear that
about about because once you cross state
lines it's a real problem
yeah I guess I mean I don't yeah I've uh
so it's one of the weird things I've
I've never so many one in my life did
drugs but because of that well because
of the DARE program I've never done a
drug worked on you because of the one
person here program first I took a oath
and
I stay do it but the DARE program back
then was so backwards that they would
just tell you if you did drugs would
either die or go to prison such [ __ ]
Garba
so my mom was smoking weed and my dad
was in prison and I so I spent my whole
junior high yelling at my mom like that
opposite of most yeah kid relationships
cause you're gonna die mom the dog that
was not there buddy yes I I know nothing
about drugs have never done a drug never
good yeah I guess uh I think they're
probably in the just say no campaign I
don't I think it probably caused more
problems because they just made it so
black and white
yeah and then when people did do drugs
or experiment with marijuana they would
feel so much shame and guilt and it was
like I don't know and it just well I've
been talking about it on stage a lot
because they also don't they don't tell
you how much [ __ ] you're gonna miss out
on yes this point in life I ever [ __ ]
yeah what everyone's like at the end of
the night I've had a couple girls like
hey you wanted to go back to my house
and smoke a joint or something I'm like
I'm like a lame nerd that got to go home
and they're just like all right I'm like
ah it is funny you talk to people that
don't drink anymore or sober and they're
like you know everything's great I feel
healthy I'm I'm happy I've got great
relationships she's like but you know I
I don't see that as like as many girls
like yeah you know but maybe when you
were drugged you maybe if you were sober
and you saw the girls you were [ __ ]
when you were drunk you wouldn't want to
do it yeah that's true - when is your
birthday branch September 23rd September
23rd 1977 you don't have to give me the
oh I don't care I'm not Hollywood you
know it's not going to change
good just talk about when trying to tell
your dad how did you try to kill your
dad can I out that yeah I mean it kind
of it has to do with the birthday story
right well let's start with the birthday
and we'll what yeah so a lot of it
started from when I was a kid that my
dad would always say he was going to
come for my birthday and like a sucker I
believed in the first couple times so
there was you know I always had a great
stepdad and then I had a good guy means
didn't have a rough you know life
growing up but it was just that promise
of him always coming yo you know blowing
out the candles and still looking at the
bro
skating doors like is he going to come
in or not for 60 so it's like the
birthday by dad
he messed them up a lot on that day
because he would always he always made
promises that he I know and and another
thing that a part of it was like what
almost got me in trouble is my dad would
always promise that he would send gifts
yeah so I would run home everyday and
wait for the give and then for a while
he was doing it yeah and then he stopped
because he went back to jail but he
didn't stop making the promises right
right so my parents would go buy these
gifts and then they would wrap them up
and send them to the house covering for
my dad oh my god I need to be from your
dad and being the piece of [ __ ] that my
dad is instead of my mom eventually said
you know quit promising these kids all
this stuff we can't afford to give them
two birthdays right and my dad just kept
getting AMA see ya so then we mean
that's addict behavior like promising
and not being able to not even really
knowing what you promise probably yeah
and just outlandish [ __ ] yeah like like
you know like he would just promise
stuff that was ridiculous and then so we
would run home every day and wait for
the packages because they came the first
couple times and then they didn't and
then so I would say mom what you know we
call ups where's our packages because my
dad would just stick with the story said
I promise I sent him so then eventually
she's my dad I my mom's just fine like I
don't think your dad sent him and then I
came to my dad with that you know he'd
call collect and I would talk to him and
I would not only that my mom had to pay
for these [ __ ] conversations and my
dad told me and my brother that he sent
me a said what he thought happened yeah
was that the UPS man was keeping our
packages and taking him home to his yeah
that's at it but this is it's always
blamed someone else yeah so me being a
dumb I mean I'm like 12 my little
brother's 10 and so we made a plan we
grabbed got to other neighborhood kids
and so my dad one time when my dad came
home he taught us this thing we took me
and my little brother swimming at the
swimming pool yeah we got out of the
pool and we were taking a shower and I'm
taking a shower and my dad comes in he
goes son
get out of the shower yeah and I get out
of the shower and he goes he said son
every time you take a shower from now on
before you get in the shower put the
water on as cold as it can go and then
get in that cold water in shadow box
until you count to 15 why is he telling
you and I was like why would he do that
dad and he's like son the way your body
reacts when the cold water hits it is
the same it'll react to ever get stabbed
so if you ever get stabbed you'll be
able to fight for 15 so my dad doesn't
[ __ ] 12 year old I get idiot I did
that [ __ ] I was like 90 no I'm gonna do
it tonight and I got a girlfriend and
she's like why what are you doing so my
dad teaching me how to like throated run
a double play that's teaching at it
basically he's teaching you how to fight
when you get stabbed yeah so like idiots
we had that lesson and then so we there
was two neighborhood kids in my
neighborhood that were just badass kids
so we told him that we thought the UPS
man was doing this yeah so we went up to
this diner by our house and we stole
these two steak knives
and then we made this plan of following
the UPS man and then if we got to his
house if it's kids at our stuff we were
gonna you know we're going to get them
so we you're gonna stab we're gonna
fight it yeah so we follow ups man which
is easy when I stop in every to lock
yeah and uh another queer bunny hopping
with steak knives on our bikes like yeah
it's scared and running with scissors
and [ __ ] yeah yeah of course we follow
him all around the neighborhood then he
goes back to the hub and then he gets in
his Jeep and drives right off and we
can't follow him thank God and like
idiot my neighborhood buddy's like you
got to throw those steak knives in the
in the there's a lake by my house I
guess they saw it on movies like so the
policeman's go throw the [ __ ] evidence
in the yes so what is this I mean are
you truly believe your father on this or
is there is there a nugget oh I believe
my dad 100 400 I got guys stealing your
[ __ ] yeah cuz I don't my dad's never
lied and the packages that came right my
mom never told us we thought it was a
college doing like now I'm good you know
my stepdads like an appraiser yeah which
was a good job but we're like my dad's
been in college like we thought my dad
was like doing really good and yes my
dad had the balls of coming home and
being like you know do good in school
I'm working my ass off because they all
stuck with a lot and we were just like
hey your kids Wyoming we didn't have
st. and what is the longing and this may
sound like a stupid question but what is
the longing to see and be with your dad
because you do have a male figure in
your life
yeah I do because it's you know it's
your dad man just because it's my dad
and my dad was so big on on that even
when he wasn't around he would always
just tell us you know I love you guys so
much he'd always say blood is thicker
than water that was our thing and he he
was like a macho dude so it was always
like here my sons and I think he felt
jealous about my stepdad right so it was
always when we talked - remember you're
my son so he kind of made it so we
couldn't get away from it did your dad
alive now yeah somewhere all right oh
sorry so you the UPS guy drives off you
got the [ __ ] steak knives and you're
supposed to dump him now even though he
didn't do anything with him yeah so we
dumped him
and then so then like stuff like that
just and then the birthdays to follow
yeah be like we would get cards from my
dad yeah but it was obvious it wasn't
his handwriting it came from my
grandparents and stuff so it's like
we're not you know if I get one card at
like 13 and one card at 15 and he's and
he's as much he's done way better at
college
Eddie's on my college yeah we're like
wow his penmanship got a lot better and
just kind of it was just kind of
insulting that they thought we were dumb
enough after the after my mom set us
down and said she just gave me an
envelope full of paper newspaper
clippings and said here I want to be
honest with you this is your dad you
know and your dad will call tonight if
you have any questions this your your
mom kind of wiped this story away yeah
what was the truth that what it was
about 30
I was about to start junior high school
and the newspaper clippings were what
like this man was arrested just like his
sends like go to Leavenworth Kansas drug
trafficking Korky just like newspaper
clippings like cut out with it is a
crazy day for you yeah so I was like I
was shot because I thought my dad was
like this perfect angel yeah and then
the college yeah so then to read that
and I was like and I was stunned at him
I my mom said well and I was I was upset
and uh you know I went outside when I we
had a tree house and I just went up in
this tree house and I was just crying I
was just because it I thought the one
again the DARE program like my dad was
in prison like to me that was like the
worst play I mean I was little place
yeah so they said your dad's going to
call tonight if you have any questions
and then my dad called that night but he
didn't answer any questions because he
was throwing a fit because they told him
my stepdad wanted to adopt us yeah
that's his kids yeah and my dad threw a
fit yeah because he's like you're a tow
blurrier Tobler and I in a so that whole
conversation was like you're my son and
all this you know don't let say no to
all this and we didn't even know that he
was going to do it so I was so confused
not only I was all [ __ ] dude it's just
confusing yeah I mean and you're also
learning the truth about your dad for
the first time and I had so many
questions but he didn't wanna talk about
that he just wanted to discuss that I
can't get adopted which I say in the
book is the only good thing my dad ever
did for me
yeah because even though my stepdad was
great if he would have adopted me I
would my name would be Brant Huff and
dick that is my four little sisters I
would sell more comedy albums my little
sister is named Haley hope and dick
Haley and uh wasn't of course later in
life my dad gets out of college and he
steals my identity and just [ __ ] up my
credit so I'm like when Bret Huff and it
didn't sound yeah maybe I regret nothing
so sure I do
so then my dad kind of like you're the
parent yeah I know what I mean like
you're telling your mom don't smoke weed
yeah it's like you're the responsible
one this is hilarious yeah so it was the
exact opposite so then my dad just
disappears and then so fast-forward to
we get to Phoenix and then one day I get
that letter and I go meet him and then
he's like you can come to Vegas so then
I'm actually moved to Vegas and I get
that job as a runner yeah and your mom
cool with this and she would not really
but I was like I was you know I was just
mesmerized by Vegas and I was cool too
so what happens I went and I spent five
days with my dad me and my two best
friends who also didn't have like dads
growing up yeah and we had like so
having fun being 20 in Vegas with my dad
was like the coolest thing my world so
we fell in love with it and then so we
all three dropped out our families were
furious with us this is what one weekend
in Vegas will do here and we live and
also just being dumb asses from Wyoming
we didn't know about
casting or anything we went to try to
get jobs as pirates we're like because
you saw the pirate ships
now I remember Irish if there's no we're
just watching like drunk tourist girls
scream for these passes they jump off a
ship
we're like what in the world can be
better than any acrobatic yeah with
James and [ __ ] just one chicks are so
hot and once an hour we're like yes so
then we got there and of course we
didn't get hired we didn't like we're
idiots and my friends end up moving back
home go back to college and then but I
was enjoying my time with my dad so my
dad you know we were just it was just
cool to be around my dad yeah my dad was
on parole so he had to be good you know
so we lived in this trailer park
hit with his girlfriend in this trailer
and even though it was like this is the
cocktail way yeah see whenever I go to
Vegas I sit somewhere I have a drink I
see these beautiful cocktail waitresses
and I'm like who who was [ __ ] these
girls yeah and little do I know they're
in a trailer park fun oh yeah my dad's
grew up and lived off the strip I'm like
Boulder Highway yeah she I'm sure she
was hot at one guy but right he you know
she had great tits but she was weathered
for she's been doing it for you know my
dad it does be Vegas will be Hannity let
me look like she'd been there for watch
sweet lady but yeah he was worn out and
uh so we live there so everything was
going great with my dad and uh it was
just cool and I had this job and I was
making a ton of money so I rented this
beautiful house on a golf course nice
and then I told my dad and it was right
by his girlfriend's trailer eyes like
just come live with me and then you can
go see your girlfriend whenever and I'm
gonna get my little brother to move down
and you're making good money yes I'm
making a lot of money so ash probably
hungry cat yeah no no worries
so when you place a $25,000 bet on the
Lions or whatever how do you get paid so
I was on salary okay which got to be
like a you know 1200 but then they paid
for all expenses he gave me a car paid
for all my phone and everything but then
as I figured out how the game worked
when they would so we stabbed next house
and they would just give me point
something so he would go you know I'd
get a BP hey look for Detroit minus
three if you see it yeah then somebody
go hey code Detroit we're looking for
Detroit now but then sometimes you just
go Detroit Detroit Detroit so when I
knew and that means like I don't know
but ah but yeah so then I would go up
and I would bet
say three thousand for me that wouldn't
move the line and then I would bet the
max for them I got that three thousand
because I rise I kept the money with me
24/7 365 so I could mess with my figure
again up and down on Mondays I just had
to do a figure check so if I was below
yeah sometimes I'd be down like five
thousand i okay I got it I got a tighten
it up here and don't so your bet you're
basically using their information from
their money or their benefit and you're
yeah as well ah but that just made me
work harder cuz then yeah they didn't I
don't think they cared because they
because then I would just try to get it
to make sure I got the bed in for myself
yeah and then get their bed yeah over
they never knew what I was doing but
they're not done by any means you were
smarter yeah I mean you're not the only
runner that's doing this yeah that I got
a deal but then I had it but they loved
me because by the you know by like year
three I had it where they were we were
doing a lot of [ __ ] you weren't supposed
to yeah like I was betting games way
past like I would have bet that Yankees
just came to my cup 17th inning last
night which is very frowned upon is it
really so they just over time because
you know they don't pay those right so I
figured out if you just tipped the
ticket writers or something uh they'll
let you do whatever you want because
they don't make enough money so so
anyway we were a again I was making a
ton of money everything was great my
little brothers just like a little
stoner dude that lived in Portland yeah
just run in a subway so I convinced him
hey move moved to Vegas and we'll be a
happy family
yeah and so he moved down and I got him
a job at this stuffed animal store and
Caesar's Palace and he was that's the
dream he for Subway sandwiches - [ __ ]
yeah but he loved it cuz he liked to go
to concerts and there's a lot of cool
they said he was doing good and you know
we had most nights would go back out on
the back porch and just sit and catch up
and my dad would tell us about prison
and we'd tell him about the stuff we
missed so everything was going great and
then I and then my dad got off parole
and so the night he got on a roll you
got a you got to be sobered ya check in
we got to be sober and he had this this
lady hated to have to go down new piss
test I think once or twice a week or you
have to call and get the color but he
hated it you know he did this lady so he
would always just say
you know that it was just ruining his
life and he would always tell us once I
get out prob I'll be a man again I can
be myself they won't control me I see so
he got off parole and it was a big day
and we had a big-ass party for him and
yeah all the family came over and
friends and we had a great night and
then at the end of the night we were
just it was me my dad and my brother in
the kitchen and we were just you know
all very emotional and just like you did
it you know we're so proud of you yeah
you're out of prison yeah you you you
didn't violate parole the families
together yeah I got a house brothers
here yes it's great everything's great
and then we went to bed and that's the
last good memory I have a my dad is
crying because uh like literally the
next day he he start back on drugs and
so I'm like 23 25 23 at the time about
yeah 24 my brother's 21 he's 22 and so
my dad starts hanging out with like
these little wicker kids like 20 year
old like white dudes that want to be
black gasps just like that worse yet
dudes in the world yeah better like our
age yeah
so he starts to bring them over to the
house and once again I'm like the dad
because he's going up your house he's
going up to his room and locking the
door and like I'm like a kid I'm like
you doing up there yeah and he won't and
so I could tell everything was going bad
what was he doing drugs
yeah so doing drugs and like my and so
for this like two week period everything
was going bad so then my friend came to
town yeah for my birthday so he eyes me
on my birthday for my friends for my
number 23rd September 23rd and uh so
they come to town and and one of them's
Walt we we were having a great time we
go out at night everyone's crashing at
the house my dad's kind of in and out
but not really around so of course one
of my friends wallet ends up missing
okay so I must break into my dad's room
we gave my dad the master bedroom just
out of respect when we got the house
even though I was paying for everything
and he I find my find this wallet like
hidden under his sink behind all this
stuff but all this stuff [ __ ] stole
your wallet which is when the worst
conversation I ever had was to go I had
to go tell my friend hey man I'm sorry
my dad stole your wallet it's so I mean
your life
it really is completely roll reverse
yeah normally it's the it's the father
that said you know like he
I'm sorry but my son stole your wallet
or without Jesus Christ so so they and
then so then the day of my birthday came
yeah and it was just kind of a flashback
to when I was a kid yeah I was just
still waiting for him to say happy
birthday or I love you son or something
and we and on the day of my birthday we
crossed past like three days in the
house and he didn't even he didn't even
say anything to me and it made me so
[ __ ] mad and then yeah and then we
went out that night and they bought me a
[ __ ] my friends bought me a birthday
cake and we got ate like half of it yeah
and when I came home that night yeah my
dad and his friends had ate the rest of
my birthday cake that said Burton but he
never L didn't even acknowledge didn't
even acknowledge my birthday so I woke
up the next 9 24 hours like and I just
knew it was about it was bad yeah I just
didn't know what to do and it's hard to
yell at your dad you know like you say
in the roles reverse but it's hard to be
like dad and I was like I got it I got
to get out of here
something that ads going to happen yeah
and I just knew it and uh and then sure
enough like the following week my
friends left and the fine I started to
spend the night at my boss's house more
I just had a bad feeling but I just
didn't want to I don't know for some
reason I mean why wouldn't he he knew it
was your birthday yeah do you think it's
because he knows that he let you down or
he like is he afraid to acknowledge it
because it's just a [ __ ] ego thing
like nobody I mean it's so weird I have
no idea if it was just the drugs or if
it was just yeah maybe maybe didn't but
I just had to assume he knew it was my
birthday I mean people are in the house
singing [ __ ] happy birthday and he
damn sure knows my birthday when he
needed to steal my identity so what I
think he didn't know my mother's maiden
name my security my birthday right so I
knew it was going bad and I and I wanted
to get out but I'm in a lease I didn't
know what to do and as I'm trying to put
together plan for me and my brother to
move out and I talked to my boss every
day about breaking the lease and then so
on one Sunday on a Saturday night I come
home from so on Saturday college
football I'd have to be after it but
like 8:00 a.m. and tell 8:00 p.m. and I
would just run my ass off and try to
make more money for them when are you
actually running running yeah up and
down escalator
wrong way security guard yelling at me
breaking every rule because you wanna we
got to get there fast yeah I give a [ __ ]
about this here - guard I just want you
had to beat the other runners yeah and
uh so I'm exhausted I come home and my
dad's there and he's you know he's
definitely [ __ ] up a little bit but
I'm like hey dad if you want to come
down tomorrow I'll comp everything get
your private booth you can drink eat and
watch football let's go in and out
because I'd have to bet the games and
then I'd have a break and then bet the
halftime y'all have a break yeah
and for NFL is more you know so I said
if you want to come down I got you on
everything up we watch football and hang
out and uh so he goes okay so I go to
bed it's like 10:00 because I got to be
up early and I'm exhausted I crash out I
like 12:30 my brother comes in wakes me
up and he's like Brant Brian wake up
someone stole my money and I jump out of
bed and my little brother had saved up
like $350 to fly to Portland to watch
his girlfriend graduate from college and
uh so I run downstairs could be like dad
one of your little [ __ ] gangster
friends stole Ryan's money better get it
back so I'm running around the house
looking for my dad and then I go and I
opened the garage door to see if his
cars exceed this Camaro that he thought
was so course he had a Camaro and it's
all in what he has always had to be
parked in the garage no matter what so I
opened the dude was just so addicted
Ixion's behavior yank take take and then
so I opened the garage door just to see
if his cars there and then his car's
gone and then it hits me Oh should I
have all my money upstairs and I ran
upstairs and he stole eighty thousand
cash from me and he's out and he's gone
so I you know I just start crying
punching the floor and my little
brothers crying and we're just sitting
there and I'm right and you don't ever
think there's a misunderstanding you
think this aw it's a stolen no but
because I put the money in a box under
my bed yeah it's not I just left it on
the counter yeah my brother had his own
he tucked away yeah and then that's what
made me sick about it was like okay you
stole $80,000 from millionaires not
saying it was okay but maybe on your
head you crash like that but then they
go sue your sons $350 and like a Fossil
watch I brought my brother and correct
that has no pawns or value right and I
see my little brother crying and I'm
like I brought him into this and that's
the moment I was like imma [ __ ] kill
my dad me kill him so then we so then we
got in the car we drove around
looking for my dad all night trying to
find them and we couldn't so then the
next morning I had to call my boss and
say I was sick I didn't have the money
to go to work and I still had like this
false hope I could get the money and
this is this is basically a lot of your
boss's cash right all this it's all I
work money if you work yeah so that's
all it's his my I'm not laughing at you
don't know I got this [ __ ] situation
yeah hot mess yeah so I have to buy some
time so I called my I call my boss and
I'm like and luckily in the mornings
it's busy because footballs getting
ready to go so I'm like I'm sick I just
can't do it and he's like alright if you
feel better we need you out there just
but he has no time to ask questions
right so then we spend the rest of day
trying to find my dad and we're exhaust
cuz we didn't really sleep then my dad
finally comes home at like 9:00 the next
day just yakked out and just and then
what was his drug of choice I don't know
I imagine like everything yeah but
probably like math and coke I'm probably
shitty drugs when he didn't have any
money and then when he had time yeah I
don't know I mean I don't I just wonder
like like what are these Bender's that
he's staying awake for for three days
and [ __ ] or yeah I mean I imagine
because when it started to go bad I just
distance myself from it so yeah I would
and my boss had this 12,000 square foot
mansion so I would go there in like a
happy world alright and I think a little
bit of it was my dad was jealous of my
boss yeah because my dad was the guy
when we were kids that had a lot of
money in his pocket I thought everything
was the big shot and now my boss was
like he was the coolest dude in the
world and my boss is so the first year
boss comps you the meals and you live
life and I live a lifestyle I never
dream I mean I was rich yeah [ __ ] I
have Mercedes and should I never dreamed
right right and so when I first got
hired so my boss had a partner when my
when my boss hired me my boss's partner
was gone back in Kentucky for like a
month taking care of his family but then
when he came back he thought I was FBI
plan Oh Mike because so then the first
couple months I just had to spend every
day with my bosses while they were
grilling now in hindsight I realize they
were grilling me yeah then they realized
I'm just a dumb ass get to my helmet
from because I he's wearing a wire yeah
because I was a really good basketball
player growing up and I when I got to
Vegas there was only one indoor gym and
it was like 125 bucks a month to be a
member of or just all the rich and remus
people in Vegas but I just want to play
bass
well so I got a gym membership yeah but
my other boss was like so you to tell me
this [ __ ] kid right move to Vegas to
be a pirate but he goes to $125 a month
gym but he lives in a trailer right so
he and they had some problems in the
past the FBI so I think a little bit
that first month I just was living this
life I would barely come home I think my
dad was jealous cuz we were doing really
good as father-son every night and then
I was like I mean crab legs and [ __ ] and
Isis restaurant I think there's a little
jealousy with my dad so yeah then my dad
came home and just said all these awful
things to us and told my my family that
we're just irresponsible and we lost it
and he was like the youngest son and my
grandparents always believed it they
just believed him yeah and and I guess
people just don't want to think of daddy
and do that to their son so he just said
all these awful things came home after
stealing your money being gone for two
days stealing the fossil watch and then
starts attacking you yeah and then we
wanted to we were screaming at him and
we want to [ __ ] him up but where he's to
a tougher than us yeah he was in
Leavenworth like when the hardest prison
so he's got facial scars from my real
riot
you know riots race riots and stuff so
we were like well we can't beat him up
so we just yell at him and then he would
just say like the meanest [ __ ] to us you
know and he saves the meanest things to
my little brother and I to you know just
saying that my mom was a [ __ ] and he
didn't even know if he was really his
dad and a horse you my dad and then I
see my little brother cries like we're
out of here yeah so then we made a plan
I was like that cinnamon [ __ ] we're
gonna kill at that how far from your
birthday is this this is the week after
yeah just the whole yeah so it's I know
this is supposed to be about my butt so
it all kinda know no no no we're good no
this is your meeting your birthday cake
would actually is the thing that pisses
me off them yeah well it's not
acknowledging yeah that's what that's
what it really started turned so then
okay so we made a plan that we were
going to kill them and then um so what's
the plan so that's kind of it's
obviously a dumbass plan out and this is
before like breaking bad or Dexter so if
you don't know how to kill somebody
probably your first plan is going to
suck yeah I mean people get good well
it's kind of a funny plan so when when
my brother moved we'd have these back
porch conversations we'd sit and drink
beer and and at one point my dad's like
hey when did you
he need me the most I was like you know
what dad when I was like 19 I got an STD
yeah and I didn't know what to do and
and all my friends like if you know the
doctor they put like a q-tip down your
dick hole and I was like oh my god yeah
so I was like a baby set this little kid
at the time and then his little his
older sister got her wisdom teeth pulled
out so she had some penicillin so my
friends are like just take some of that
penicillin and Christ so I I did it and
then I told my dad this story and as I'm
telling the story turns like bright
white like he saw a ghost and I was like
what I thought he'd think it was funny
and he's like son when you were four
years old I got sick and they prescribed
penicillin I almost died I'm like
deathly allergic to penicillin and he's
like if you would have been you would
have died and I just laughed as like
well I didn't my dick cleared up and
yeah we thought it was funny so fast
forward when this happened I was like
this is it right you know it's like the
game uh oh sure like I knew the murder
weapon but I didn't know what rumors I
did to it so penicillin is the weapon I
call my cousin Kato who he lived in
Phoenix and he's like a real gang member
like who's the youngest person ever go
to Wyoming Penitentiary our families
what a great proud moment and but he's
the most loyal dude in the world and I
called him and I told him what happened
and he's like I'll be there in five
hours and he drove straight from Phoenix
to Vegas and he got there and he's like
where's he at and I was like no hold on
I got a plan yeah just gonna kill the
[ __ ] food and I was like I got a plan
that I think will keep us all out of
trouble yeah he's like what's your plan
so I told him so there's a Jamba Juice
like three blocks from where we lived my
dad would love these Jamba Juice's I
would get these mango Jamba Juice yeah
yeah so what we're gonna do we're gonna
get some penicillin we'll put it in the
Jamba Juice and we'll give it to my dad
my dad will drink it it'll die okay I
just wanted just to [ __ ] do you want
to kill ya he was like we'll just [ __ ]
pat him down and just and pinned it on
down his throat i was like no trust me
so i said that's what we're gonna do I'm
gonna go to Colorado we would be with my
girlfriend because everyone will think
it's me and no one knew Kato was there I
said what I need you guys to do is just
get a Jamba Juice fill it up with
penicillin give it to my dad then when
he load up all my brother's [ __ ] before
all this
yeah then give the penicillin to my dad
when he starts drinking it then you guys
just get in the car drive to Phoenix
peace out somebody will find him dead in
a few days yep in a girl in the kitchen
or wherever
yeah
so they're like alright so you know Kade
get some penicillin what and teen yeah
so I fly to Estes Park and I I call him
the day of the thing and they're like
I'm like are we ready he's like we're
ready we're in the fridge large mango
full pennies on waiting for my dad to
come home so my dad comes home and they
give him the Jamba Juice and he doesn't
drink it he just puts it back on the
kitchen counter and like I know he was
probably shocked to see Cato even there
and but yeah other than I remember my
dad was in like real prison and at that
time were enemies suing I'm taking yeah
I'm your enemy yeah he's and uh I don't
think he probably were trying to kill
him
he he didn't drink it yeah then I called
Kato back like an hour later like what
happened is what's going on and they're
like he wouldn't take it
I was like man you know what [ __ ] it
just go to Phoenix stick with the plan
I'll come back and I'll just move out or
[ __ ] out we'll just break the lease and
never and I won't talk to him we don't
murder somebody
yeah and Cato's like nah [ __ ] that like
I want to do it say I didn't come for
this you know we're going to end this
and I was like we've time buddies I got
we got a plan I was like William you had
a plans like we got a plan and they need
to hung up didn't let me ask any
questions so their plan was this that
they so they knew my dad always had to
have that dumb Camaro parked in the
garage
yep so what they did was they open the
garage door and then they cut the power
in the phone lines and then they just
waited in the corner in the dark waiting
for my dad to come home and then like
sure enough like a hour later my dad
came home and he parked his Camaro in
the garage hitting the button trying to
get the door to shut and it wouldn't
shut and he got out of the car and then
he went and he shut the garage door and
locked it and I started to walk through
the garage to go into the kitchen into
the house yeah and then when he's
walking in the house my brother and
cousin jumped out with the golf clubs
and try to kill him with golf go to real
ROG but what they didn't so they hit him
pretty good a couple times like a bunch
of kids trying to kill their dad yeah
not really knowing how to do it
yeah but they the mistake they made was
there was no light in there because the
power yeah so they're swinging away in
the dark yeah so there's only like one
there's a there's a door that goes to
this side yard that leads to the garage
like a door door and on that door on the
bottom there's a little doggie door so
that's the only light coming in right
and my dad in like survival mode sees
that light
just puts his shoulder down and just
runs breaks through that door and falls
into the yard and jumps over the back
wall onto the golf course and he runs
away [ __ ]
and then I never that's it and that's it
and I never seen him ever again and you
and your brother went down and moved
with you then or well they left to
Phoenix that night because they were
scared after trying to kill him he got
away they got in the car go to Phoenix
how many years ago was this
17 17 you haven't seen him since I
haven't seen him or talked to him do you
think you will no I hope not you hope
not I tried you so I didn't talk to
anyone on that side of the family for
like for a long time and then you know a
couple years ago my uncle reached out
and I started talking to my uncle mainly
just to kind of monitor what he's doing
yeah but he so he lives in Vegas okay
and then but I guess he so we tried to
monitor him just to make sure he doesn't
come back in my life right right but I
guess he told his friends he wants to be
like a Rekluse and he's got like Hep C
I'm just hoping he dies but yeah yeah
got hips he probably won't die so I have
to live in I don't know if he did I
think he's got to feel guilty he's never
tried to come back into my life but I
don't talk to my grandparents on that
side oh yeah any of them yeah but I like
if I'm on a first date or something and
I started talking to a girl and we start
talking about her family I'm like yeah
just really want my dad to die and
that's like it's pretty aggressive
people are like wait what and well then
I explained it anything to hear the
story yeah but there's no like you know
and then I'll meet like churchy people
and [ __ ] now like well what about
forgiveness and like we forgave him a
millions yeah there's no fixing it so if
he comes back into my life it's only bad
because I can never you know I think not
that you need it for me I think you're
probably right to stay away yeah yeah I
mean and he's just been shitty to
everyone his whole life and what's the
what what so yeah what pattern I don't
need I'm not going to change yeah yeah
so that is he's not going to ruin that
is the worst birthday ruin any more
birthday that is the worst birthday and
it still wins but yeah that's true
Candice Thomas was bad but this is
definitely the first time someone on
this show has decided on their birthday
or close to their a member of their
parents
oh I hope how do has to well it's a
fascinating story and if you want to
hear more stories you have to listen to
your listener buy your book
yeah by the book that it definitely
touches on this but there's you'll hear
what happens after I try to murder them
and then a lot of other crazy stuff
happened the people millions of dollars
go missing people died it's a pretty
pretty little kid from Wyoming it's a
pretty interesting yeah it's a it's a
cool story uh I'm also baffled to learn
that penicillin will just wipe out an
STD I go huh
that's Jessica unfortunately I can vouch
for it twice in my life
why is Brandt Ober where can they find
info on you and the book okay you can
just find me Brandt over comm and I'm on
all social media it's just Brandt be are
a and B t tl-- bler and then the book is
on Amazon Barnes & Noble Kindle audible
and you can if you want like an
autographed copy you can go to Brandt's
bookstore and then I'll sign one and
send it to you or you can just buy wears
brands bookstores that on your ransom
branch bookstore okay got a code all the
ending by Kendall audio a hard copy
autographed or paperback autographed
there or and it got all that set up
everywhere else yeah hardest thing I've
ever done good job but it was great
online such a door making is annoying
yeah it was the whole thing has been I'm
so proud of the book but it was the
hardest [ __ ] I've ever done yeah well I
appreciate you sharing the information
is your podcast still up and running
yeah and then I have a podcast of the
3131 I've done I've been a guest it's
super fun he just asks his guests
thirty-one questions and the some are
meaningful some are silly they're all
really fun it's a good pocket so thank
you thanks for being on this thank you
buddy all right see it great stuffs
perfect Thank You bud that's a hell of a